[Music]
we have to talk 13 reasons why oh yeah I
loved season 2 I have to tell you and I
think Jessica's journey from start to
where she ends up is so incredible and
so emotional to watch how did you feel
about her journey in this season as an
actor it was a dream come true because
it was such a challenge to have to
portray someone going through the
aftermath of dealing with her trauma and
I feel like her story story needed to be
told Jessica's because we don't get to
see the aftermath really played out in a
realistic way and the payoff is really
good because all that really matters to
me is to have women who have gone
through that we relate with it and feel
like they're not alone and I can't tell
you the reception I've gotten it for
that like the messages and like people
I've been able to meet and fan
interactions and even acquaintances so
it's um it's I'm constantly learning and
I'm just so grateful that I get to tell
this story with the trial I talked to
Justin Prentiss and he said it quote
pissed him off
support the ending how did you feel
about I guess the the resolution to the
trial it's supposed to piss you off but
the sad truth is that it happens way
more often than you think when you have
a rich white guy going against a black
popular cheerleader
there's race elements to it there's
privilege there's so many different it's
just a classes thing and it's yeah it
just goes back to privilege and that's
what happens and it got we drew from the
broad Turner case and Ron Turner got to
walk away with a slap on his wrist so it
just happens and you're supposed to be
pissed off just think about all the real
woman that is actually happened to and
be more enraged and use your voice to do
something and make the change and shift
the culture and want it to be alive you
know
[Music]
what did you make of Jessica and Justin
getting back together in the finale that
is a very complicated question because I
as Alicia it was very upset because I
didn't want her to go back you know cuz
the kind of is toxic in a way but then
you see the redemption Justin has and
then you can't judge Jessica for making
her own decisions because she's finally
coming to terms with her sexuality again
and feeling like her body's her own
again so at first everybody I was really
angry but then I realized I was Alicia
and I was judging Jessica and then I
thought Who am I to judge Jessica and I
feel like a big point that a lot of you
guys as actors have made is that the
characters are all flawed and that were
not supposed to see we're all flawed do
you think though in season three that we
will see more repercussions to some of
these decisions that the kids are making
no idea but I really hope so
I talked to Devin droid and he said that
he would love to see his character Tyler
explore the aftermath of male sexual
assault I'm curious about your opinion
on that and what you would like to see
for Jessica in season three I mean I
think Tyler's development's character
wise is going to be incredibly
interesting it's always been one of my
favorite storylines because it's so
interesting it's going to be inevitable
that they were going to catch up with
Tyler in the aftermath and I feel like
especially for a male being sexually
assaulted on a popular TV show and then
being able to show him trying to recover
from that will help a lot of people and
for Jessica I hope that she will empower
other girls around her because there's
so many other schools people in the
school I've been you know harassed or
assaulted by Bryce or other jocks so if
she kind of gets empowered by that and
helps those girls
[Music]
[Applause]